So, I ask you this question about the alcohol and phosphatase.
Still with the normal limits.
Did they do any other tested to look for any possible metastasis?
So, if it was me, if I was your oncologist, I may want to just,
I would possibly suggest a PET scan.
If they did a PET scan recently,
when was your last PET scan? That would be my question.
Again, you're still with the normal limits.
Certainly, alcohol and phosphatase could rise, so let's talk about that.
What could cause alcohol and phosphatase to rise?
Congestion of the liver is the first thing that you think of with elevated alcohol and phosphatase.
So, someone who does not have a diagnosis of cancer, you think of a congestion of the liver.
Taking incense, so Tylenol, Advil, can cause elevation of alcohol and phosphatase.
Taking other medication can cause elevation of alcohol and phosphatase because it's irritant to the liver.
So, those are your first things that you look at.
With a diagnosis of cancer, the other thing that can cause elevated alcohol and phosphatase
is the bony metastasis. So, if there's metastasis to any bone that's causing
the lytic metastasis will cause elevation in alcohol and phosphatase.
So, that's a differential diagnosis that you want to rule out.
What's going on with my liver? Typically, if I have metastasis to my liver from cancer,
that's not necessarily going to cause elevated alcohol and phosphatase.
It's congestion of the liver due to a medication usually or some sort of toxin,
toxic exposure, can cause it as well. That's what you're looking at.
So, differential diagnosis, elevated alcohol and phosphatase is toxicification to the liver through something,
or if the person has a diagnosis of cancer, if there's any bony metastasis.
Those are the things that should be rolled out.
Again, your alkaline phosphatase is still with a normal limit.
So, but still, if I was your oncologist, I'd at least suggest, should we do a PET scan?